so I'm I'm Bob DeSimone I'd like to
welcome you to the annual McGovern
Institute symposium this year's
symposium that has the had its topic
selected by mayor de Jesse re who also
put together the the whole program and I
know he has a goal for the symposium and
by the end we will all have an internal
model of what an internal model is my
role is only to thank all the speakers
for coming thank the audience for for
being here and to thank the McGovern
staff who organized the whole event this
is an all-hands-on-deck kind of event
and I know they worked very hard to make
this a smooth-running a bet so I will
turn it over mayor dad I'm really really
pleased with a sort of symposium lineup
of speakers we have probably most of you
know most of the speakers the initial
point of this symposium was some time
ago when Bob suggested that maybe I
should think about the next annual
symposium for McGovern and what what
would be a topic that I'll choose if I
were to to organize one I thought for a
while and I think one of them sort of
one of the more elegant conceptual
frameworks that has entered the field of
neuroscience in the past several decades
are ideas that come sort of in an
interdisciplinary form bring together
concepts from engineering from sort of
theoretical modeling and experimental
work and and one of the more promising
ones among the various possibilities
that are out there is the concept of
internal models partly because it's
ambiguous but but hopefully the point of
this symposium would be to actually
think a little bit harder about this
ambiguity and whether we can bring
together some some sort of a common
understanding that will bear on models
and mechanisms across scales
and you know I want to say a little bit
about the speakers will will mostly talk
about the ideas around internal models
although I I have my my thoughts that
actually I'm even among the speakers
some will have you know views against
very strong sort of claims about what
internal models are and what they're
used for it's it's not an easy concept
to embrace specially if you want to you
know go go a little bit deeper about
what what you mean but the idea is that
the big why it's valuable it's fairly
straightforward you know a lot of things
that we do in all sorts of behaviors
that we engage in involve you know
several main conceptual problems that
thinking about intermodules comes to
help one is ambiguity you know the same
sensory input can have multiple valid
interpretations you know all of this
famous I don't even know where the
source of it comes from this but this
class this this dress illusion blue blue
black versus gold you know like this
that's the same input we all see and we
have very different interpretations of
it across the the population and perhaps
the reason is internally we think about
sources of light and all sorts of other
things that must must have been in
certain ways so that the interpretation
would make sense for one brain in
certain way for another in another you
know in a different way and it goes
across scales it's not just for visual
illusions of that kind
you know from as Nate's talk will will
indicate you know the simple act of
whether knowing a sensory input is
coming from the outside or from my
movements of my own body is a
fundamental ambiguous problem that the
brain has to solve and that requires
some understanding internally of what it
means if I move my own hands in other
words the sensory areas might have some
sort of a model of the consequence of
the motor command
similarly goes for another concept like
ambiguity which is uncertainty it is
fundamental that you know all the
internal activities inside our brains
and also from
the outside the information has has
various forms of uncertainty associated
with it and is fundamental to the way we
behave that we make inferences about the
state of the world based on not perfect
information and the way to do that again
is to have some knowledge about the
statistical structure of the world world
might be a particular brain area that
another brain area wants to make use of
so if area B wants to listen to area a
and if area a has some variability
associated with it well the only way we
can make sense of it if it has some
understanding of the language that the
the area a speaks and it also goes
fundamentally in a sort of into the
notion of dynamics as soon as you think
about a dynamical system and we behave
in a heavily dynamical environment then
we are dealing with situations where the
smallest forms of noise and variability
will propagate into a dynamical system
into generate more and more erroneous
kind of a consequences and States and
therefore as a as a good engineer always
you will need some sort of a feedback or
control mechanism to to harness the
dynamics and as soon as you want to do
that then the control mechanism needs to
have an understanding of the way the
system can go awry or what are the
sources of noise in the system so all of
these concepts bring together the need
for some part of the brain to have some
knowledge about how another part of the
brain operates and that's in the
broadest sense the the idea behind an
internal model now the language that we
often apply to think about internal
models at least from a sort of a
computational perspective
just because ambiguity uncertainty and
noise and dynamics all are well captured
by the language of probabilities it's an
easy formulation to bring into sort of
our world of understanding to learn
something about these notions of models
but there is a there's a tension there
you know just as a an apple falling from
the sky we might have an equation that
explains
it's dynamics it doesn't mean that the
Apple actually implements that equation
and the same way as an experimenter when
we come up with an equation to explain a
particular behavior that doesn't mean
that the brain actually implements that
exact same equation and that's the
tension between having models to explain
a behavior versus what is it that the
neural circuits actually implement and
that's it's really high at the bridge
between algorithmic modeling concepts
and neural circuit motifs and what I
hope to invite all of you to think about
as the speakers go through their
presentations is whether whether the the
the knowledge so far will lend itself to
building a bridge of that kind where we
can link computational models that
explain behavior at a cognitive
psychophysical level to more lower level
neural circuit mechanisms that in
perhaps smaller animal models have been
studied and if not other ways that we
can adjust either the way we formulate
the models or the way we interrogate the
neural circuits which can bring about a
common language between the two because
it's a fundamental sort of a disconnect
that still exists between models of
cognition and circuits of sensory motor
system in lower animal models and with
with that in mind I just want to tell
you the the sort of the plan for the day
is that we will have half of the
speakers 5 of the speakers will speak
during the morning there will be a break
I I think you all have the program there
will be a break in the middle but the
the morning talks are more geared
towards neural circuit lower-level
mechanisms and then after lunch there
will be another 5 talks with another
break and the talks in the afternoon are
sort of slightly more bent towards
system level descriptions computational
principles and cognitive level sort of
representations of internal models again
with all in
it's that and at the end of the day
we'll have a panel discussion with you
know some of the experts on both ends of
the aisle hopefully engaging each other
in in in ways that you know will will
either we'll learn there is really no
connection between what a sensorimotor
lower level understanding of an internal
model and what we call a cognitive
internal model or maybe there are
linkages and there are circuit motifs
that we can think of that could even be
used to understand more high-level
aspects of internal models and without
without further ado I'll pass on the
podium to our first chair mark Arnett's